WAYNE: Oh, there's
something big.
SHELBY: There's
something right there.
What the hell's going on here?
Oh, [inaudible] [bleep], boy.
That don't sound like wood.
SHELBY: Oh, it's a big
son of a bitch, ain't it?
Something's down
there and it's big.
Let's go get with that
trackhoe and see what's here.
There ain't no way
I can pull us out.
The boat ain't
going to pull out.
I need a damn trackhoe
to pull this out.
NARRATOR: With something
big lurking down below--
Here we go, man.
All right.
NARRATOR: --there's only one
tool to get for this job--
I need power for
this one, junior.
Here we go.
Ah-ho!
NARRATOR: --his
trusty Leviathan.
Going to get him now.
Man, we on something big.
I hope I can dig it
out with the trackhoe.
Get this for Mr. Wayne.
It might something
valuable to him.
WAYNE: This is very exciting.
I've never seen or been involved
with nothing like this before.
This is unreal.
SHELBY: I really want to
find it for Mr. Wayne,
but I'm having a
hard time finding it.
There's something there, man.
Can't pick it up, too big.
Won't go around it.
Here we go.
Got it.
SHELBY: There he is.
WAYNE: All right.
SHELBY: Boy, that's
a good one, Po-Po.
I got to go take
a look at this.
SHELBY: That's a
big one, ain't it?
Man, them stones really did
uncover some big treasures.
You got it.
[inaudible] Look how big that
[inaudible] is on that thing.
NARRATOR: Shelby went
hunting for treasure.
WAYNE: All I know is it
come off of a big, big ship.
NARRATOR: And it looks
like his ship just came in.
There's treasure
out there, man.
It's everywhere.
[inaudible], junior.
WAYNE: This the best dredge
you and I have ever done.
Let's go put it
on [inaudible]..
WAYNE: It's going to be an
attraction, I'm telling you.
NARRATOR: A few
weeks ago, the swamp
was tore up and spit
out by a wicked round
of storms and floods.
What's going on, man?
I see you guys [inaudible].
You're going to love
this, I'm telling you.
This one's good [inaudible].
Oh, man.
Yeah.
NARRATOR: And with his bayou
brothers and sisters hurting,
the swamp superheroes
swooped in to save the day.
WAYNE: Is that fine?
That is good, man.
NARRATOR: Now, thanks to
Shelby, the treasure hunt museum
is back, bigger than ever.
SHELBY: I seen the
anchor on display.
What a rush.
Glad I could help him out.
NARRATOR: Along with the find
that'll keep business humming.
It's not only a
big deal for me,
it's a big deal
for the community.
It's all about celebrating
our heritage and our history.
It looks a lot different from
when we dug it up with that--
Yeah, it did.
It's a whole lot
bigger, ain't it?
WAYNE: And look, 3 T.
It weighs three tons.
SHELBY: I know it was big, man.
WAYNE: 6,000 pounds.
Boy, that is good.
We chained it down so
no one would steal it.
Right, put it in their pocket.
WAYNE: After doing some
research on the anchor,
I think it is from 1901 to 1910.
If it wasn't for
you, we wouldn't
have this here for the
general public to look at.
SHELBY: Yeah, Mr. Wayne's
museum is back up and running.
That's important to me.
It's important to everyone that
lives down here in the swamp.
You get to see that stuff.